okay
all right people um i'm here today on
this
it was a real hot day today you know um
i kind of want to talk about some
some some some demoralizing things i did
under influence alcohol and drugs
uh i am a drug addict i'm a i am an
alcoholic
um for those who don't know that means
that i cannot control once i take a hit
once i take a drink i cannot control
what i do
everything that everything that i say
i'm gonna if i'm
if every everything i say i'm gonna do
if i take a drink or a hit before i
prior to doing it all bets are off
um when i was a child
uh my first addiction when i was a child
was um
basically actually it was it was it was
it was actually sex because when i got
molested
i liked it you know i like the way it
feels to like when the when my baby
sitter got on top of me she started
rubbing the vagina on me i like that
[ __ ] you know i liked it you know i was
i know i remember i remember thinking
that
all women anybody anybody in my family
anybody else that i was with alone
i wanted to have sex with anybody
because i thought because i liked it so
my first addiction was sex
i remember when when when this thing
this this thing would come on like 11
o'clock at night we had to go to bed
early
we'd be in my grandmother's house and
this thing would come on tonight it was
called love american style
and i love america and said well come on
and i heard that they would always talk
sex at each other and i would always
wait because
it was like i would wait because i
wanted to see them do i just thought
they were going to have sex i just i
just wanted to see it because i walked
into one of my cousins which i'm having
sex he was doing it to his girlfriend
doggy style and i was looking i was like
goddamn i think
i think i kind of did one of them but
anyway that's my first time doing one of
them
the first time getting one off so i
really like sexting
so anyway as as as as time progressed on
i had um
i had i had but now i thought go back my
i was my
my my self-esteem was messed up because
my dad was always telling me that i
wasn't [ __ ] i wasn't just saying that i
was thinking about this the other day
because
my best friend i'm gonna call him r ron
we were all in there we're about six
year old we're all in the huddle of
people and um
they were they were they were fighting
you know how guys are guys okay we
you're gonna fight me i was always
afraid a big [ __ ] big [ __ ] [ __ ] just
scared a fight you know so they were
they were all fighting in the street and
and then and he looked no lewis you
stand back because
because you can't fight you ain't these
big thick glasses you wear big thick
glasses man you can't fight so i said oh
i was scared anyway i said well good
night now and get out of here now i
don't have to fight me i'll just say
i wear glasses nobody beat nobody can
hit me nobody can beat me up you know
so as time went on this is one guy
going to become my best friend and he
would he would he would beat me up you
know he would he would he would
literally hit me and beat me up
and he would grab me by my collar man
and he would take me we're going to go
steal the pizza man
we're going to [ __ ] we're in
elementary school and one day we
we cut class and we were actually going
to the pizza place and i was actually
going i was so scared of this dude i was
actually [ __ ] gonna do it
he said no man i wouldn't make you do
that are you really so he did to me
until i got into fourth grade
so there's this girl named named l and
we were walking up the stairs and he
told her he said look man
he said he said watch me i'm a punk i'm
a punk louis
and why he ain't gonna do nothing so he
hit me in the side boom give me heart in
the side
she turns on like she said louis you're
gonna let him punk you like that
you a [ __ ] i'ma tell all the girls in
class you were [ __ ] so i hit him back i
hit him back
kind of hard he said man that's all you
had to do in the first place
this guy became my best friend
this guy became a very very we were best
friend we were buddies all the way up
we were just buddies buddies buddies
that i got into deep into my addiction
i'll get up there later
so like i said my first edition was with
some
was the sex thing so i got about
i don't know so years and i went into
liquor store i saw i saw a club magazine
club man i had to have all these white
girls with these big fat asses and just
white girls and big fat ass i always
liked their microbes and big fat asses
so i bought one of those books and
around this time i was little my
grandmother so i stayed like down in the
dungeon like so
and i didn't realize it but every time i
had a little halfway job every time i
would get paid
i'd get one of them [ __ ] magazines i
must have had 200 of them solo [ __ ]
stashed all around stashed up on the
thing stashing the stash your stash oh
my god oh my god
so anyway that's i'm gonna go back a
little bit now
my my first my first i was
17 years old and jimmy stratton handed
me a joint at the party and i hit the
door he said oh
oh louis i thought you were al7 you're
cool now
well i had always thought of i'd always
had a little self-esteem on nobody
i'm sorry i can't play sports you know
i'm scared of the girls i'm scared to
talk to girls
and i never just didn't think i could be
anybody to do i always had just a really
really
[ __ ] up self-esteem really no no no
just a
sorry you know so so and then and all my
friends and my brothers and sisters they
would always tell me i'm you dumb you're
stupid you're sorry you're lame
you're no good and so this kind of stuff
the average i think
what they were doing where they were
trying to reverse me they were trying to
make me
you know stand up get some balls and be
different but but
i took it to heart and in my stoop i'm
just still here
i still feel like that when i'm not
drunk i still to this day have to get
drunk to talk to a girl oh yes
okay anyway so where was i i was back oh
i'm going back i'm going back
so uh uh when i had i became an
alcoholic
and first thing i did
oh my god this lady really liked me a
lot big healthy she really liked me like
she had bought me all these gold chains
i was drinking always 800. now my father
used to beat my mother all the time beat
my mother's ass all this time oh
i said i would never do anything like
that i would never [ __ ] do anything
like that
so miss me this girl grabbed the chains
off my neck and she she was so big she
was a big girl it's like big women she's
about 200 pounds
she grabbed my chain and scratched my
neck and she slapped me in the face and
her hand was so big
felt like a man hit me bam so my
reaction was i hit her and i hit her
i hit her i hit her i hit her hard i hit
her i hit her she weighed about two and
i hit her i'm knocking from my i knocked
her about my four or five feet and she
flew in here like this and she had this
portion she
just bought so she had this great big
brother who's who weighed about
300 pounds who played football for the
for the urban day high school
and and he and i can hear him coming out
the door i'm gonna kill you [ __ ]
i'm gonna kill you
so i jumps in my car and i take off
running and i'm scared to death
and everywhere i went everything because
we were all in this like in the same
neighborhood
you know and everywhere i went i would
see him they would he had this big black
cadillac his big black spooky looking
cat he would always come up behind me i
know
they talk about how you carry guns i was
afraid he was going to shoot me
so anyway my buddy stan had took me down
to the
hq and he bought he had he had a 22
pistol
and he had me by the bullets for his gun
and my name
so about the fourth time they came up to
me you know i'm i'm i'm i'm scary but
you know
anybody you can push to walk push and
push push the dog to the wall i wonder
he's gonna start growling i said [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] him up
so i go to stan's house and i get the
pistol i said damn i'm crying tell you
give me what's wrong with you man you're
going crazy give me the pistol give me
the [ __ ] piss don't know nothing
about a gun and never shot a gun got my
ass out there
so i knew they were up there at the
mcdonald's on rose cranston central so
i drove the car and i remember i
remember when i when i backed the car up
that there's there's the glass of
mcdonald's over here and i backed the
car up you know
and they're in the mcdonald's and
they're sitting there and when i'm
looking i
thought i want to go like that i get out
the car i go i walk up in the mcdonald's
and i go i got the tip of the pistol in
my pants i read up and said now let me
tell you something this is going to be
the last time either one of you
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me
i said i said i i did i i did hit the
lady i said yeah i said she hit me first
i said refreshing i said i apologize i'm
sorry
in your sister i'm really sorry i'm
really really sorry
i said but i'm not going to take this
[ __ ] no my dad i'm not going to deal
with what the gangster doing in the
movie i'm not going to take this
man i was shaking like i'm sure i'm
going to i'm drunk i'm shaking like a
[ __ ]
scared they're going to kill me that was
that but um
that was the first thing that i had done
and then
my stepmother had two sons that went
with us
and i remember i had lost my job and i
had my little last little change in my
water on my bed and i came home my
little step brother they took my money
on my wallet
and i beat him up i beat that as a kid
oh my god
since mom called my dad at work she says
louis is over again god damn fool he put
his hands on my kids
i don't know why i've never seen louis
act like that lucy i've never seen him
act like that
he said put him on the phone so he told
me he said get your [ __ ]
and get the [ __ ] out of my house he's if
i come home and you're not to get your
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] where you going
he didn't he didn't he didn't give a
[ __ ] about what what he
he he never asked me what happened it
was just get the get your [ __ ] get the
[ __ ]
he never asked me whatever i said
goddamn why don't my dad love me
so then so we were we were talking one
day and
i ended up leaving the house i never
said i never said my dad's matter of
fact i had a little 240z car and i
stepped in the back of my 240 until my
my girlfriend the big girl allowed me to
i was sleeping under her bed
you know she her she stayed in her mom's
house and i stepped on her bed
god know if her mother called me her
mother couldn't stand me because you
guys
so when i was climbing through the
window and the sheriff's the carson
sheriff's coming around the corner
and they see me hopping through the
window and they say hey
what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm like
hell i got my ass halfway through the
window
at and they they said they come in they
give me they got me to gaffle me up just
like they always do us and they put me
on the grass had my face all in the
grass and [ __ ]
so she wrote no no no no no he's he's my
boyfriend he's coming to spend he's
really coming to spend the night with me
they were cool okay we're sorry but hey
man i had so much grass and [ __ ] in my
face you look like i've been playing
football or some [ __ ]
but anyway that was that that was
another uh demon wiser thing but here
comes the hero
my my best friend back to my best friend
i ended up getting an apartment i
little small little apartment in my butt
my buddy came over to here he had just
he had a really he had a classic votes
had a 69 volkswagen he sold the 69
volkswagen he knew he was drinking
but he didn't know he didn't he didn't
know nothing about no drugs i kept that
hidden so he came to my house
he said man he told his mom and i'm
going to stay with don donny i got his
own apartment stay with don
and he gave me he gave me forty dollars
to put in my coat pocket for groceries
the next day
groceries are pretty cheap so he said i
sold a book let's go buy us a hooker
take her to the house let's toss her up
flip her this way flip it that way you
do the back out to the front you can
keep on going until
you so as we we were drinking we were
drinking hennessy
and i was drunk and
the drug the dope talked to the dope
talked to me the dope said hey man
he was he was he was what he was she was
sucking right he was sucking my neck and
i was [ __ ] her and my [ __ ] going
soft and the dope said hey man
uh let's go get this while they [ __ ]
let them [ __ ] we go get some dope
they don't let them do that so i did
that and i went to get the door when i
came
and the girl told me he said come on
come with me to take the girl back home
i didn't want i i wanted to hit so bad i
was out i needed a hit
man what's wrong with you what's wrong
with you louis come on man take come
when you take the girl home
no no so i wanted to when they got out
he happened to leave his wallet oh my
god
he left his fight i want to kill him and
i said why did he do that
why but i'll be cool i'll take one hit
i'll take one hit
and i'm not gonna [ __ ] with his wallet
[ __ ] i went through about two or three
hundred dollars his money
and so he comes home he gets up to go to
work the next day he said man my money
is funny in my water man i wonder what
the [ __ ] happened you know
tom you're my best friend what happened
no did you take my money or did i lose
it so he came back that night was he had
a girlfriend he had he had
he had his this black girl from some
black ghetto girl from compton who's
so i told us hey man i said man i got i
think i have a drug problem you know i
said
i took your money i'm spending on drugs
god that hurts me so bad
nah nah my best friend had sickle cell
that hurt him so bad that i killed him
like that
because he was tight and it hurt him so
bad until he got sick and that he went
to the hospital for about a month for
about a month he was an author
that's how that's how that's how he
couldn't believe that i would do him
like that and his poor mother's mother
me his mother
and no one's and she couldn't believe
that i would that i would screw him over
like that
so they would so before he went to the
hospital they were sitting in my
apartment
and i had and i had called my
grandmother my grandmother they gave me
250
to pay the rent the rent was only 350
dollars and she gave me 250
so i gave it to him i feel so bad i gave
it to him you
i know and getting getting put out of
the apartment so i ended up going when i
went and then
that was my then then so oh then that's
not what you say
that's what i want to say my grandmother
my poor grandmother oh god
one day i was need my high
but i left her person on the side of the
couch
and i took four dollars out of that
purse god damn
that hurt her so bad that hurt my
grandmother's so bad my grandmother's
crying
my grandma remember when she got hurt
when she when she when she really got
when she really was in pain she would
she would she would seem you know she
could sing really good she was almost
100 years old and she would start
singing
and i said well i said i said grandma i
have a truck problem sorry
i told the truth come on i got a trophy
i'm sorry i stole your money i don't
know how
so i'm still down in the room smoking
and she comes down in there she says
don't worry about it baby you told me
the truth
i love you you told me that's that's
what hurt because she didn't get mad i
feel like she said she should have shot
me beat me or something she
said baby you told me to chew i'm gonna
call your dad get some help i was like
oh no don't call dad oh my god
i just knew my dad was gonna kill me now
my father this kind of guy
he was a hard ass he was always on my
ass about being too slow being too dumb
being to this she was like a big coach
you know you did this wrong
no you did that wrong no you're never
going to be this no he never met
and never seen my daddy soft didn't
think he loved me at all
he came out god god bless him he's dead
he came back wherever his house i was
sitting
on the bed and he pulled the chair
beside his bed and he
he did like this he just start crying i
never think about he's dead
it's my fault he says my fault
mr grandma told me yeah you're probably
stolen he said it's my fault
and i'm so sorry i'm so sorry that i did
i treated you like this i'm so
sorry and i was thinking myself
it's not your [ __ ] fault i picked it
and then i thought then i thought to
myself well i gotta
shoot now yeah [ __ ] is your
goddamn fault [ __ ] your fault
yeah it's your fault
now i didn't keep doing it so anyway
here am i here my stepmother well i know
i know a program they could put him in
here so
they're going to take now they're going
to take me to see now i'm i'm missing
bright
now they're going to take me to see the
psychologist now they're going to take
me this
my dad worked for a big aerospace he had
he had some she knew some people he took
me to psychologists as a lady
psychologist
in fact she was fine i'm looking at her
titties think about what i can do to her
and first of all i asked her i said have
you ever hit a crack bite have you ever
taken one with jade honey been out all
night long he already hit a crack bite
i said very very cracked by i said i hit
a crack pipe i said one of the most he
more than anything i look a little
homosexual stuck in my dick when i was
small crack i didn't have no more money
no more dope i live so i said if i
cannot tell you [ __ ] like that would you
be normal
she's
so i told my i don't want to talk about
i want to talk about psychology so then
they end up taking me to this really
really really ritzy bitsy
program you know i still had a sports
car and i go over there and i had my you
know going on my clothes on and i
remember
me and one of the guys i was hanging
with was telling me we
we we we were in a.a you're going to hey
you know you can you can still do what
you do you just can't pick up a drink
so i went to the bar and i said i said
give me a long eyelash cheese no
no you can't drink dude you're an ay no
no i have a crack problem i don't have
an alcohol problem
see here he was i was deluded right
there well i have a i have a i have a
crack problem
but the alcohol is not really a problem
you know just that's not a problem
that's he's sleeping long eyes down
anyway i started drinking again
lo and behold i rented the car out oh my
god i rented i rented i had a really
nice 260 i rented my car out
and i could hear i put i had the glass
back mufflers on and i could hear my
[ __ ] car going around the whole
[ __ ] city and i couldn't couldn't
catch the [ __ ]
so the next day came over so my grandma
said she called the police
she said you know all folks are smart
boy
you know who got that goddamn car you're
going to tell them chef who got the
gamble damn car saw okay so i thought
yeah i said
big big red got the car okay they want
to be red house
we really said my sister will be they're
gonna bring the car back so i hear the
car
coming down the street i got the car
back one no big thing i was like okay i
gotta wait at that time
so then my dad took me to this place in
canonical park to go to rehab
they put me in rehab and i'm i was
i'm a i like to drive forklift trucks
i'm a driver i drive anything i can
drive any [ __ ] thing
they put me on a forklift and put me in
ash's yard where the donations come in
for the salvation army
the guys come from mexico and they and
they buy those different things so
you know i'm so i i'm i thought i'm
gonna start selling this [ __ ] so i'm
selling all the people [ __ ] i'm selling
all salvation army [ __ ] so they found
out that guy could they kick me out
this guy called my father you say your
son's [ __ ] up you got to come get him
we're putting him out my father says i'm
done with him i'm through with him put
his ass out
there i mean canoeca park way out in
don't have don't know how i'm getting
home
she came home went to another program
in the silent sideways north in santa
monica one other guy and i went out
there and got where the guy was driving
on the truck with a guy he went and he
had
he had the mexicans come and buy some
stuff off the truck just he would pay me
40 50
a day to keep my he keep quiet well one
day i stopped at the liquor store if i
went home
and i came back up in the sally and the
guy who wanted to play said he was so
cool he said you know
when you drink going in a rehab they put
you out he said he said man you so
courageous man just go upstairs and go
to bed
i'm not going to tell gulfton i said man
no [ __ ] that i got
i got i got rings i got rings ropes and
shoes and tennis shoes that's once i
take a hit i'm selling all that [ __ ] i
need to go get my [ __ ] so i can sell it
i need another hit
you know so i'm i'm selling all this
[ __ ] you know
then i got this now i got this then i
got this girlfriend i know i know that i
[ __ ] up on it i went to another rehab
whenever you have in palm springs i
stayed there eight months i was
i was jesus but all i knew was jesus we
we god down god don't forgot don't
strike me down there because i know a
lot about the bible
and i was so full of the bible when i
when he got there eight months and one
day man i just needed a hit you know i
just and i needed a [ __ ] hit so bad i
just
couldn't i didn't understand where it
came from i just needed a
[ __ ] hit man i need to fix it in my
god so i
i had a few dollars saved up so i got my
winning weapon palm springs and i took a
hit
damn here's a god because i'm going to
palm springs and i hitchhiked all the
way to los angeles just with my thumb on
the damn tin freeway i don't know i
would never do no and i did that in the
guy i met a guy on a truck and he'd
drive me in the truck you know
that's what i wanted to drive when i saw
him just when i saw him shifting that
truck
that's what i want to do drive a truck
so anyway
adam b that's that program
that's when i came home and my mother
allowed me to stay with her
for the first time since i was my mother
my mother left with me my mother left me
when i was in the fourth my mother were
tight and she left when i was in the
fourth grade so my life was always
[ __ ] up with women because my mother
left me i always
think that my girlfriend's gonna leave
me because you know my mother left me
so my mother let me come stay but i
stayed with it for three months and i
started
using and she she put me in a water bed
and i
took the hot pipe and put it up on the
water bed and all the water came out the
goddamn bed
just said what happened to the baby hot
pipe over the hot goddamn crack like
oh [ __ ] and i'm high on crack well
she ended up putting me out here so i'm
gonna stay with my brother
and he had his girlfriend and my
girlfriend told me that his girlfriend
wanted he wanted to [ __ ] me
i said no oh she was she was hot and she
was hot and um i said no i wouldn't do
nothing so anyway one day
i was drunk and she came home she came
home with um
by herself she did him here and her
brother went out and she came on by
herself
and she kept telling me man your brother
man he's with some of the girl you know
and i'm just so hot i just know what to
do i'm just so hot i'm just warning i'm
just so hot and i didn't mess with that
girl but i mean
i i mean i sat there cause she she said
well i'm going she was in there taking a
cold shower it took everything
i just couldn't mess with my girlfriend
my my brother's girlfriend i just
couldn't do that
anyway he comes home he's swerving down
because he was in the shower when he
came home we scored him now she's taking
his sharks we had done something
no man so we had gotten into a fight he
put me out of his house he's pouring
down [ __ ] rain
i'm out in the street one more time but
all my [ __ ] and got damn garbage bags
here i go again
because of my drinking and using the
same one more time
i went to another rehab and uh
i don't know so many ways i've been to
68 [ __ ] rehabs
i relapse from every [ __ ] single one
let me go let me let me go back when i
was with my daughter's mother oh my god
poor lady i had a nice little job
driving a truck i get paid every friday
so the guy's at the liquor store when i
watched the goal he knew when he
knew when friday came at 6 30 afternoon
when he went
when he heard the embrace popping he
knew with me i'm going to buy a whole
lot of liquor
i'm in there buying liquor and about i'm
i'm on this 18 i'm bringing liquor and
i'm going home and she's coming home and
then you know
she's a crack at it too she she knows
she's being found she's pregnant she
needs to stop she
she needs to stop well i can't stop
bringing home on fridays but
this this is this this this thing this
is what makes me an
attic and alcoholic i told her
week after week after week after for
about a
well house or nine months for a bit i
told her for nine months every friday i
said baby this friday i'm not
gonna stop at the [ __ ] liquor store i
told her that what
look with everything and i was since i
wasn't even crying baby i'm not gonna
stop at the liquor store this friday
and bringing all the money home um but i
mean i was serious
i'm serious as a [ __ ] i'm
serious
the next friday i got a push i got got
another bottle i came i said baby i
[ __ ] up this week but next weekend i'm
not gonna [ __ ] up i did it week after
week after week after week after week
after week after week after week every
week
and as i go up to the store i'm just now
realizing that that's the that's the
whole thing of alcoholism is you just
can't you just ain't got no power over
it
and and the the the most demoralizing
thing about being an
alcoholic is here i am a man
and here's something is it here here's
this alcohol here's this little this
little this little this little yellow
rock is
and they they have to have i tell you i
tell that cocaine is the finest white
woman in the world she ain't got no
[ __ ] she ain't got no face ain't got no
lips she get
all my [ __ ] money and i ain't [ __ ]
her yet you know
same thing with the alcohol i take a
drink alcohol but the craziest [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the world
is is my my family god
just the [ __ ] just to see my family in
pain like that
but but but and the fact that they they
were thinking they were thinking that
they were thinking i'm rushing i'm going
i'm guessing they my family was thinking
that my family was thinking well well
well
dude you got a kid coming you know you
things are things you're getting older
my dad said you're getting older but
you're not getting any smarter you're
just getting dumber you're just getting
dumber and dumber dumber dumber dumber
number
with that i'm gonna stop doing it well
grandma mama stop doing it but tell my
girlfriends i'm gonna stop doing it
i had i had the girlfriend and i had to
had the girlfriend in houston you know i
was supposed to go out and i relapsed
and took a hit and she came over
she she said you do it one more time you
know now i'm gonna do fellas white girls
on black girls take this [ __ ] white
girls they ain't having that [ __ ] she
said you got one more time yeah you had
one more time to do that [ __ ]
and look at the next time i did that
[ __ ] i went over a house same thing in
the rain all my [ __ ] in trash bags
sitting on the porch bye you gotta go
here i am one more time
out in the [ __ ] street nowhere to go
i walked out with my bags
oh my gosh so then i met another girl
and i did her
i'm in another girl poor day i mean i
met there moved in
moved in the apartment with her had her
mother gave us and we were running a
fleetwood cat like we were so we were in
a we were sober i relapse one time
took off with the [ __ ] pickup truck
for three [ __ ] days nobody knew where
i was i was someone crack
i was so high on that goddamn [ __ ] i
didn't know how i thought i was
i thought i was only been out there for
a day hell i've been out there for three
[ __ ] days i had that's all i was i
was
i lost about 20 pounds i was stinking
and i caught him i said hey dude what's
up she's like mm-hmm
yeah [ __ ] said bring my mother's
truck home and don't bring your ass like
i went home and she let me she let me
back in but good old dab she was
thrilled because she was
she was an age she was an alcoholic but
she was sore but she kind of let me back
in there
things didn't work out you know so i
just i just kind of left her there you
know
and i really heard her i really i really
heard her in her mother man god she
called my dad
this [ __ ] called my father and told him
mr banks oh my god well this
lewis is down here really tripping man
he's he's relapsing on that [ __ ] he took
my mom's truck you know i saw a costume
i had i had my porno magazines
and my crack pipes in the bathroom on
top of the shelf
i to this day i don't know what made i
was in the bathroom
shaving my face and she walked up in the
bathroom she stood up on the toilet she
grabbed the porno magazines in the pipes
she threw him on the floor
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing in my
[ __ ] house
you talking about the most embarrassing
humility i
felt so [ __ ] low she said you're
smoking crack and looking at
what's wrong with me what's wrong with
this you know i'm like baby nothing
wrong with that
every now and then i just like to get up
she said well you got to go one more
time
i'm out on the street got my [ __ ] in
them green glad glad bad well thank god
for gladbag glad badminton keep me and
holding me up i walked off them got them
clapped back
here i am one more [ __ ] time
me and them [ __ ] gladbass anyway
that happened tonight then i no i got it
then i got i got a real good job with it
would have
with a guy who had a trucking car he had
a big trucking company now he
he his daughter liked me a lot his
daughter was just was his gym and she
liked me a lot and she came in my
apartment one day she had a handful of
crack
oh my god she and i started
smoking crack her father found out and
then he said we have to go to rehab so i
went and i went to rehab and i went to
rehab and
she called my father and why these
[ __ ] always call my father like my
father you know what they just like my
father
and then she was i didn't even know she
was keeping in touch with him so he even
came he said i came to houston looking
for you you know your friend told me you
were in rehab
she said her dad bought you a truck you
know and i came back
and then everything was good and then
one day i didn't show up and work won my
three or four days i'm smoking crack
again
and i end up getting fired you know that
would happen then so now i'm out now
now here comes the day where i guess god
didn't forgot any little ass whooping so
i was
i was sitting at the gas station
panhandling this white guy comes up in
the back around he got long hair he's a
guitar player
some kind of bands hey man i need to get
some crack show me where the rock is
shoot let's get in he said give me three
hundred dollars worth i'm not thinking
he could have been the police
but i mean i'm a little maybe i'm a
musician i knew i knew
i knew he was i didn't feel like he i
knew he was he was a real musician so we
went to the spot where i used to go to
the mexicans and to get the rock and
he opened up the van i said hey man give
us 300. i want the [ __ ] he looked in and
said man that's the [ __ ] police he
slammed the door
guy ended up giving me a hundred dollars
for helping my anyway shot my dumb ass i
walk back over there
to buy the dope went on foot here these
guys are they're surrounding me now
i'm still not thinking i'm just i want
to hit i don't know i'm not thinking
again
one guy said man why did you bring the
police to my [ __ ] spot i said
what do you before i could
before i could finish talking wow he got
me in the jaw you know
i'm trying to run like they hit me and
i'm trying to run and remember he had a
he had a pet boy and his pet pool named
petey he said
get him petey and i remember i remember
hearing the dog man i don't think
i was running so fast god damn i was
running over here i'm running around
like i hit it
i heard the dog i'm looking back and all
of a sudden i don't know it's like
it's like it's like it's it's like the
fear just left me dude it's like the
fear just left me
and i turned around my bar i said come
on [ __ ] if you run up on me i'm
gonna bust your goblin you think you you
think you got a big drawn out witch and
the dog just [ __ ] stopped
and turned back around and ran back but
but as i was running from him i fell
down and i remember
i busted my hand open my hand was spit
wide open i went to the fire department
and
they they laced me up they took me to
rehab
here one more time in rehab and i got
caught [ __ ] screwing around and
wanted to
throw in one of the the counselors a
little white counselor she liked me i
liked her i mean i got caught screwing
her
one more time i'm out in the street at
least these these were blue these are
the blue
they have hefty they haven't had the
blue ones just not the blue bass and
blue pairs
one more time with the [ __ ] bear i
said what is the problem with this
goddamn bag
so then four minutes then there's poor v
b with a lady i met went to church one
day because i did go yeah
hell i was hungry i hadn't eaten three
days i want to go to go to church and
they feed you so
v was there and v likes to take men home
and
take care of them so she was in and i
was sitting in the front of the van and
she said god told me to take you home
with me and let you
in that you dry out i was like damn it
is a guy so she took me home with her
you know
you know when there was civilization on
the standhouse you had to read the bible
there which is cool
you know you had to read the bible with
her and also and then again i started
sneaking my crack in there and going in
the bathroom turning the shower on
smoking my crack
and she found out one more time i didn't
have
she didn't give me that but my my stuff
was inside it was in like a like a
laundry bag and started
closing outside outside whatever
get your basket and get to walking so
they're right down down down it's shit's
real get really getting back and i got
no bag i got a [ __ ] bat now
everybody see i got a [ __ ] bag i
remember throwing all my clothes like
brand new boots and she just do all that
[ __ ] in the street one more time i'm
back on the goddamn feet
i got the person i called myself i
called my sister as soon as i got to get
the hell out of texas she said she
took to my knees called and called my oh
my god dad oh don't call [ __ ] dead
they call dad that's what get him up get
him a bus ticket
i get a bus ticket and i come home you
know
i'm gonna get something not for real no
no no no no no no no y'all for
this time this this time i'm going to
really get so many i mean i'm going to
get sober this time
i'm not bullshitting it's not [ __ ]
y'all them other times
goddamn i got [ __ ] up again i did it
i'll relax again let me let me okay now
now
this is this last time around so
my mother's best friend's daughter
beautiful gym we ended up dating my
mother said don't dare don't date him
i don't want you to cheat my mother
didn't want me to embarrass her
because she knew i was she knew i was
gonna [ __ ] up but i was man i got i got
sober man i
did a little job i had i had a night of
sob nine three but i had a blue stop
night i mean i was
i was i was good i was i felt good i
felt good i looked good
but i didn't i didn't know but i didn't
know what an alcoholic was i thought i
was cured
well about eight months it went by
and my girlfriend was boring as [ __ ] she
just wanted to sit down and watch tv
and she'd like to do this every night
and go eat she'd like to go eat it but
she's a beautiful beautiful woman had a
lot of money
she would have made a perfect wife but
anyway she asked me one day she said she
was a divorcee she said
little woman she says i'm so happy with
you
this is when is the bottom gonna follow
up and i told her
oh god i said if i ever take a drink
oh [ __ ] she she she didn't hear me i
said if i ever take a [ __ ] drink oh
that's all well it was the 4th of july
it was me it was it was her mom and my
mom and her and we all sitting in the
front porch
and i said baby let's go somewhere
because i i i wanted a hit and a drink
and i wanted a drink and
i i didn't i didn't know i i didn't know
that that the alcoholism was
was did they call it the sleeping giant
that [ __ ] he gets down your gun
he falls asleep
when he wakes up hey hey [ __ ]
it's time let's go let's go [ __ ] we
let's go get let's [ __ ] up our life
again let's go for this [ __ ] life up one
more time
and when he's let's go [ __ ] life up but
i i had i have been sober for a little
while so i
but i didn't i i did i i don't i
i don't know how to live so i remember
when i used to have sex with her
my my penis would go soft and she would
say you don't even
she was she was not and she said i i
don't understand i was i don't know how
to
sex without those drugs and alcohol so
to be sober
doing that [ __ ] and i i couldn't and i
said damn and i have a brother that
dissolves the doctor i say man if
something do i need some viagra or
something i said my dick be going soft
and she says well you're
about you're up there you're that age
now i said nobody so my girl thinks i
don't like her i'm not
to her wasn't that i was i was
my disease was knocking was wanting to
get high
[ __ ] that feeling when you when you when
the disease tell you when you when you
when you when you that that takes too
much energy when you just sit back and
hit the pipe it feels itchy
it feels just as [ __ ] good and you
only have to be going through all that
and please just please yourself that's
what the
damn disease is telling me so i the
the the now the voice in my head was
really it was a really really really
really low voice
but uh and i remember i
stood up i first i once i stood up and
everybody in there
everybody's like oh what's wrong what's
going on
i said mom get in the [ __ ] car let's
go i'm taking you home
i took my mama home i stopped at the
liquor store and i didn't think about
what i was doing until like when i had
to probably cisco in my hand when i
heard
when i heard the taco and i saw the
smoke come out the top of the bottle
that like like like the i dream of genie
when i saw genie come about that bottle
and i saw them big titties and big legs
i said oh well and when i did that
it was a [ __ ] rap
god and the poor lady the poor lady was
calling me on the phone and my dumb ass
didn't
know since i turned the phone off and
the phone was for three days dude the
phone was ringing and
the girl didn't know nobody knew where i
was
and i'm in the car smoking crack in my
saw riding around the hood
i got so hot i look i tried to get the
lapd to take me to [ __ ] jail and the
[ __ ] wouldn't take me
because my car ran hot and i said you
came
are you alright i said no no no i was in
my car officer i'm not i was trying to
tell myself i
was i got crack in the car i got alcohol
in the car he said yeah yeah yeah okay
we bought out i was like god damn i
can't even [ __ ] go to jail
so that happened and in a wreck in the
car until in the crowd
but um
i did that poor lady like that you know
and and and
and and she she was even giving me
another chance you know she liked she
liked me a lot you know i said baby i
said you know what
and then i got i got sober for another
week another and i would relapse again
and i'm sorry
and i started reacting last night
finally i said you know
i left my house my landlord came to my
house
at a bmw well i know that my mother came
in my house talking [ __ ]
i i had my rent money in my pocket the
disease was telling me
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man let's go get high
[ __ ] that [ __ ] leave we can sleep in
the car [ __ ] this is what the dog was
telling me
we could sleep in the man we sleep in
the [ __ ] car we broke then we
got a painter and then we
we could smoke the whole goddamn 500
hours of money everyone do have we want
to we can get strawberries we get
[ __ ] in the car and
suck our dicks and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] it
i listen listen that [ __ ] one
time
there i am i left the house
i know i i i left it i left the keys to
my car
on my brother's bed and i left the car
at his house i had a i had a
really nice beer it was oh it was classy
it was all i left i left my brother's
house i left
nobody heard me until three months later
could you imagine
your people they didn't know whether i
was dead
in the poor the girl my mother everybody
was upset and then i i
i called monday and they told me that my
brother had died i have a brother with a
police officer he died you know
but they when once they heard my voice
they weren't they weren't mad at what i
had done but they were just
glad that i was alive so then i told him
his big this is i never thrown away
i told him this big [ __ ] lie than my
that i would i went
i would i went legally insane and forgot
i went i suffered amnesia
i forgot who they were where they were
what they were and i just started
walking
i don't know if i don't even think they
believe but i told them that i had that
i had a mental problem
you know which i know i have mental
problems and i started walking
everything
and i remember i remember
i got beat up i lost the keys to my car
i got beat up with the bully club
i parked my car i lost the key to my car
i went to go get a key
came back somebody stole my car i came
down here on ninth
i laid i i was so i had never been
that depressed i never i i just i just
wanted to die i just i didn't want it
it was nothing they mean they wanted to
live there it was nothing in me that
wanted to survive
i just wanted to [ __ ] die and it was
it was nothing to the preacher could
nobody could say nothing to make me feel
better
so i just i just i had so i remember i
remember i was it was
like broad day everybody and i just laid
on the [ __ ] sidewalk and i just i
said god let me just go to sleep
i just laid on the [ __ ] side and
there's a little young guy walking
man what's going on tell me what's
happening you know and i remember these
these priests walked by they were
preached praying for me
i mean i got that that damn bad
so then i started getting i was getting
my checks man i was i was
i was smoking up and i was smoking up
nine hundred dollars or nine hundred
dollars of [ __ ]
when i was driving i was i was smoking
up eight or 900 a week
i get paid on friday and got down by
money i didn't have no money
since i've been getting high i've been
telling myself
over and over and over i'm it's going to
be different this time next time we're
just going to get 120 i'm just going
with one bottle of beer i'm not going
i'm not i've been saying that [ __ ] over
and over and over
until one day you know i mean we fit in
within the cooking
in conclusion there's a preacher told me
he said until you realize
that there's nothing you can do nothing
your daughter can do
nothing your mother can do nothing
nobody on this earth
can do about what you doing you're gonna
continue
to [ __ ] do it over and over because
it ain't until you realize that there's
nothing you can do about it or nobody
else can do about your situation
and that kind of stuff i kind of heard
that i was like god damn that's what's
wrong with me
i can't not do it so they talk about you
have to believe in a power
that's greater than yourself now that
kind of makes sense you know sometimes
you know
i'm human you know so how we are
sometimes we believe in god sometimes we
don't believe in god
but in my situation you have to have
faith they they what they teach and they
tell you that you have to have faith in
something other than you
in order to recover from this and you
have to talk about it get to talk about
what i'm doing here you have to get get
it out i feel so much better mr mark
but you have to talk but so now here i
am
and i'm kind of i'm kind of thinking in
the right way now my social security i
was a couple hundred dollars short on
rent so i'm
you know i'm i've got the rent paid last
month i'm putting on a dollar short on
this month anyway
things are kind of going on i'm not
using as much as i used to but i'm still
uh you know i'm still saying i'm not
gonna do it and doing it again but i'm
doing a little better because i'm
getting [ __ ] done you know i'm
getting healthier i'm wearing contact
lenses and [ __ ] now getting a little
haircut halfway
[ __ ] cut my [ __ ] got my i mean i it
looked good the first time i
might hear that i look like a damn fool
like i said man my mother saw me looking
like this
oh my god but anyway here i am now
and i'm realizing that and
that but i'll is a disease
and most of us are hired because we in
in and i'm talking let me know
i i punish myself i think about the
things that the things that i told you
guys that i did i think about those
things and i punished myself well god
damn you know
it's like it's like the kids that could
cut their own arm off
well i'm i'm just i'm doing the same
thing but i'm just inducing drugs and
alcohol but it's the same thing as just
cutting yourself
i'm killing myself because because i
feel like
i'm punishing myself and so the preacher
said god don't punish why why are you
going to punish you when god ain't when
you punish you why are you
who are you to punish yourself so these
things that they were
they were teaching me and telling me i'm
starting to hear them now
maybe maybe i'm on my way to getting
better but anyway i just wanted to dump
that and
say that and i feel s ah superman a
whole lot
a lot lighter see you guys next time
is that cool
you